Hi, I'm Chris.
After 10 years working
in corporate finance,
I quit my job, sold everything
I owned, and moved here
to live in the wilderness
of Alberta, Canada
♪ I wanna get away from it all ♪
♪ Move out of the 'burbs ♪
♪ Wake up in the morning ♪
♪ To the bugs and the birds ♪
♪ Collect wood for a fire ♪
♪ And bathe in a stream ♪
♪ I be getting back to nature ♪
♪ I be living the dream ♪
♪ I can forage for nuts ♪
♪ I can live off the land ♪
♪ I meet a tiny squirrel ♪
♪ Let him eat from my hand ♪
♪ Learn the names of the plants ♪
♪ Learn the names of the trees ♪
♪ This one's Ian ♪
♪ And this one's Keith ♪
♪ Get away from it all ♪
♪ Live while I'm young ♪
♪ Ignore calls from my wife ♪
♪ And my infant son ♪
♪ I got a new life now ♪
♪ It's one I prefer ♪
♪ Living free in the wild ♪
♪ Just me and my squirrel ♪
♪ I struggle getting food ♪
♪ Finding berries and nuts ♪
♪ Feeling hungry got a rumble ♪
♪ In the middle of my gut ♪
♪ Call the squirrel over ♪
♪ Betray his trust ♪
♪ Kill him, cook him, eat him ♪
♪ And cry in disgust ♪
♪ I be living my life in the wilderness ♪
♪ Going off grid no need for stress ♪
♪ I know a lotta y'all
would kill for this ♪
♪ Forget about the past,
start life afresh ♪
♪ Quit the rat race, leave it all behind ♪
♪ Break free of your
chains, don't be confined ♪
♪ Be wild, the way that man's designed ♪
♪ And live in a wilderness state of mind ♪
♪ I wanna get away from it all ♪
♪ Like a lumberjack ♪
♪ Just me and my Hemingway paperback ♪
♪ Collect my own water ♪
♪ Shit in a hole ♪
♪ And weep as I do it ♪
♪ 'Cause I feel so alone ♪
♪ Be depressed ♪
♪ Repress my feelings ♪
♪ Then chop down Keith ♪
♪ And chop down Ian ♪
♪ Feel even more lonely ♪
♪ 'Cause my friends are gone ♪
♪ I miss them so I'm heading out ♪
♪ To make a new one ♪
♪ Get away from it all ♪
♪ Roam round in the the forest ♪
♪ In a few days come across
a wandering tourist ♪
♪ Build a fire in the great outdoors ♪
♪ Swap stories with the tourist ♪
♪ Make delicious s'mores ♪
♪ Make a new friend ♪
♪ Feel happy again ♪
♪ Barely even think about Noah and Jen ♪
♪ My friend tries to leave ♪
♪ In the following struggle ♪
♪ I crush his skull with a rock ♪
♪ So I pick up my shovel ♪
♪ I be living my life in the wilderness ♪
♪ Going off grid no need for stress ♪
♪ I know a lotta y'all
would kill for this ♪
♪ Forget about the past,
start life afresh ♪
♪ Hiding in a cabin like Walter White ♪
♪ Burn my fingerprints off with lye ♪
♪ Wake up screaming five times a night ♪
♪ Because I see my friend's
faces when I close my eyes ♪
♪ I wanna get away from it all ♪
♪ And jump in a lake ♪
♪ So I gather up stones ♪
♪ For additional weight ♪
♪ Write a note in blood ♪
♪ On the back of a leaf ♪
♪ Apologizing to my mates ♪
♪ Break down with grief ♪
♪ As I stand on the shore ♪
♪ Thinking no one cares ♪
♪ Out the corner of my eye ♪
♪ A friendly bear ♪
♪ Talk about the things in
common that we like to do ♪
♪ Turns out she's killed
squirrels and tourists too ♪
♪ Get away from it all ♪
♪ With my grizzly friend ♪
♪ Develop a bond ♪
♪ But you know how it ends ♪
(panting)
♪ I had sex with the bear ♪
♪ Then married the bear ♪
♪ Had a cub with the bear ♪
♪ Then I had an affair ♪
♪ With a different bear ♪
♪ So got divorced from the bear ♪
♪ Wanted custody of kids ♪
♪ So went to court with the bear ♪
♪ Now I'm paying huge amounts
of child support to the bear ♪
♪ Moral of the story is ♪
♪ Don't have sex with bears ♪
(wind blowing)
(bear roars)